well a crowd fan favorite segment here
we're going to go back now to reddit's
mi the a-hole forum where people present
their moral quandaries their
uh their gripes their disputes with
other people in their lives and they
want to know are they the a-hole or is
somebody else the a-hole and uh
oftentimes the advice they get from
reddit in this regard is very very bad
which is why i feel like i need to come
in here and save the day and give the
official proclamation so we'll start
with this showtime a-holes uh first of
all it says my husband
and then in parentheses is asian
my husband asian and i american welcomed
our firstborn four weeks ago the the
baby is healthy thank god but i'm
exhausted my husband's family had been
pressuring us to visit to meet the baby
yesterday i was surprised to find them
standing on the porch i was embarrassed
and felt like i wasn't ready for
visitors because the house was a ndss
y'all a mess later i asked my husband if
we should order takeout for dinner he
said no because his parents would find
this rude and unwelcoming he suggested
that i go inside the kitchen and prepare
something i said fine then went and made
some mac and cheese once i served the
family my husband's mom asked if i
really found it appropriate to serve her
in the family mac and cheese
i hate macaroni and cheese they had an
argument and they decided to go home my
husband said that deciding to serve his
family mac and cheese was more offensive
than serving them nothing at all am i
the a-hole what's wrong with mac and
cheese wow okay
so this this husband i
here's the
the note guys he's gonna help him okay i
got a notepad you want to give your your
wife like
at least a week's notice
if you're giving her a day it's gonna be
a problem but they're here right now the
house is a master can't you just you
can't do that you cannot do that if you
want to have a happy marriage you just
cannot do things like that then again
you know it's easy for me to say because
i'm never inter i'm never really tempted
to invite guests over for dinner in the
first place so that's not something that
ever really i never want to do that
anyway so i've never been tempted in
that direction but if i were going to do
it and on the on the rare occasion when
i do you know you can never give too
much notice if you can give a year's
notice for that that's probably best but
i kind of like these kinds of questions
because this is one where i get to say
you're all a-holes actually
you are all
now obviously your mother-in-law and
husband are a-holes uh imposing yourself
on somebody especially a mother with a
baby expecting a feast one of my
absolute unwavering non-negotiable
principles is that you never complain
about food that has been served to you
this is why we don't have picky eaters
in my house okay picky eaters are a
social
construct they are made not born my kids
will eat anything
anything we serve them because that's
the only option we've ever given them
you are gonna finish your dessert and
you are gonna like it but i also have to
unfortunately give you a demerit for
serving mac and cheese
yes they should have eaten it without
complaint
but i can complain because i'm not there
so i that i'm not beholden to that rule
and as an outside observer i can say
that mac and cheese is for children more
mac and cheese here just keep it going
keep it going don't be afraid of the
burned edges just give me the tray there
should be no room on an adult's plate
for mac and cheese there's so many
better more sophisticated side options
so you're all going to be a-holes for
that one when you use the bathroom you
always lock the door behind you right
well you don't want some random person
accidentally walking in on you so why
would you let people walk in on your
online data using the internet without
expressvpn it's like going to the
bathroom and not locking the door or
just leaving and completely open you
exhibitionist did you know that your
internet service provider like comcast
or verizon knows every single website
you visit and what's worse is they can
sell this information to ad companies
and tech giants who will use your data
to target you expressvpn puts a stop to
that it creates a secure encrypted
tunnel between your device and the
internet so that your online activity
can't be seen by anyone i use expressvpn
on all my devices it works on everything
phones laptops even routers so everyone
who shares your wi-fi can still be
protected even if they don't have
expressvpn the best part is using
expressvpn is as easy as closing the
bathroom door you just fire up the app
click one button and you're protected
it's as simple as that very easy
expressvpn is the world's number one
rated vpn by techradar the verge and
countless others so if you're like me
and believe your online activity is your
business secure yourself today by
visiting expressvpn.com
walsh yt use my link and you can get an
extra three months free next one says i
work a pretty standard day job and at
night i help my friend at her restaurant
which serves an assortment of thai
cuisine to be honest i'm insanely picky
but i fell in love with this peanut
sauce so about once a week i take it on
either noodles or stir-fry to my day job
for lunch thursday i took my noodles and
my entire tupperware was missing today
my boss confronted me and accused me of
poisoning my noodles because his
daughter one of the new girls borrowed
my lunch and had to be hospitalized
turns out she has severely allergic to
nuts and she ate some and boom she went
into anaphylactic shock and had to be
hospitalized now her dad is trying to
hold me accountable for her bills and
condition
uh so am i the [ __ ] well
obviously your co-worker and boss are
a-holes here is that a thing people
actually do and i hear about this
complaint a lot like this is apparently
a it's a it's a thing you bring your
food in and someone steals it
i can't even my god what have we become
steal someone's lunch from the fridge
that's sociopath behavior if someone did
that to me i'd probably i'd like burn
down their house burn it down and then
to do that when you have a food allergy
is just another level of stupid
which is why like this is a good lesson
here if you're an adult i'm listening
with food allergies that is not
something you can impose on other people
i'm sorry you have that problem and it
can be a serious problem but it is yours
younger kids are different but with
adults we have this thing with food
allergies now
where it's like i'm allergic to peanuts
and so any room i walk into there should
be no peanuts anywhere i should i should
be i should have a 50 mile radius peanut
free doesn't work that way you have to
figure out like so many other problems
we can have in life
even when they're legitimate problems
you have to figure out how to navigate
life with that problem that's on you all
that said
the person who wrote this
is also i think in another way the
a-hole as well
what a twist
of course you never steal your
co-worker's launch out of the fridge
but also you never bring a lunch
that has a pungent odor to it
[Music]
if i'm walking in the break room why
should i have to smell your disgusting
peanut sauce
so another situation where everybody
involved is the a-hole
uh
the other one says my husband and i have
been married for six years still don't
have kids we want them but it's still
not happening friends and family are
causing us constant stress about having
a baby soon but it's obviously something
we can control
so what i did was come up with an idea
to have an empty jar and call it the
pregnancy jar i carry it with me in my
bag whenever i'm with my friends and
family and every time somebody asks
about when my husband and i are going to
have a baby i pull my jar out and ask
them to put a dollar in there for asking
and they pull out a dollar and they put
it inside the actually do it it actually
worked because uh most of them stopped
asking after about four months
last week we had dinner at my parents
house my brother came back from his
business trip that lasted a month and
while we were eating he asked when me
and my husband were gonna have a kid
with my jar in my hand asked him to drop
a dollar for the question he asked i
could tell he felt embarrassed but he
immediately reached out of his pocket
pulled out his wallet and put it taller
in the jar
made my way back to my seat and uh sat
down and resumed eating like nothing
happened
this is
and everybody in the comments and i
scroll down everybody in the comments
has somehow declared that this woman is
nta right not the apple
somehow
and that is exactly why you don't turn
to reddit for moral enlightenment that's
why you have to turn to me because yes
you are the a-hole every single one so
far everyone involved is the a-hole if
you're actually cooperating with this
and encouraging this behavior someone
puts a jar in front of me and says this
is my pregnancy jar i put a dollar in it
what no get away from me you freak
people ask that question
because they're taking an interest in
you
and they want to know about your life we
all have certain questions that are
asked of us all the time by everybody
and that we're annoyed about
but that's the price of living in a
human society even if it's a little bit
weird it's still people taking an
interest in you and so that is your
responsibility to just deal with it and
make it less awkward not more and that's
the other problem is that
okay somebody asks a question to you
and it's a little bit awkward you don't
want to answer it
well the objective now should be to
neutralize the awkwardness and move on
from it as quickly as possible you've
brought everyone else into this
awkwardness i can only imagine sitting
there at this dinner table as a guest
and watching this whole exchange taking
place
how do you move on from that and have a
regular conversation
so you're all a-holes okay last one for
some background my husband and i have
been married for a little over a year we
recently bought a nice house it has a
pool and a hot tub and one of the things
i've enjoyed is unwinding after a long
day
my family has always been very
comfortable with nudity so i find it
really irritating and completely
unnecessary to be told to restrict some
perfectly harmless things such as
swimming and hot tubbing nude topless
sunbathing having to wear a bra whenever
guests are over nude grilling hot tubs
hippie houseboats now my husband's old
mom who is from a different world my
husband's old mom does he have a new mom
there's something different about you
she's a southern lady who's super
prudish and very passive-aggressive is
staying with us for a month my husband
wants me to stop sunbathing swimming hot
tubbing topless and dress up a little
bit more when having breakfast and
dinner and but by dress-up i think it
means like just dress at all he's not
saying dress up just dress put on
anything any kind of clothing at all we
have guests over please honey i flat out
refused i told her she's a guest at our
house and i won't be rude or
inappropriate i'm not gonna be rude or
inappropriate but i will walk around
nude am i the sole hero um are you the
a-hole
yes you are
and you're also
showing it off to everybody in the house
which is a good
indication that you are one that's a
rule of thumb if you're showing yourself
to people then you are one like that's i
think we could kind of take that put
that on a bumper sticker that's worse to
live by a lot of entitled people and uh
and is a common theme now maybe all
these entitled people don't walk around
naked in their house or maybe they do
but there's this this thing people do
where they expect every accommodation to
be made for them but if they are ever
expected to make any accommodation for
anybody else it's oppression so that's
the way she's living her life everyone's
accommodate to her but even being asked
to simply put on clothing when my mother
is here she can't do that in conclusion
put some clothes on you freak that's my
message to this person and indeed to the
whole world a world which is
very much in need of it i think
put some clothes on
well a lot of a-holes uh various
different kinds flying around in that
segment if you don't want to be an
a-hole yourself then uh what you need to
do right now this moment is uh
hit the like button
hit the subscribe button
and what else hit the notification bell
so you don't miss any more content just
like this